every day the perishable goods are
packed up for transport harvest fresh
supplies large supermarket chains with
vegetables grown on the company's own
fields and nearby farms
the truck interior has to reach the
required temperature before the delicate
Freight can be loaded the vegetables
have to be kept cool at a constant
temperature of two point seven degrees
Celsius during the transport that will
be checked on delivery
any eatin stuff that comes in to the
vegetables that are not sealed properly
not cooled properly goes to waste
refrigerated transport is important in a
hot country like South Africa this is
one of the 13 thousand or so
refrigerated trucks in the country the
fleet emits enormous amounts of
greenhouse gases the cargo area of most
trucks is poorly insulated resulting in
greater diesel fuel consumption and
spoiled produce South Africa's Agency
for standards the S ABS wants to make
refrigerated transports more
climate-friendly a testing hall for the
refrigerated trucks was recently opened
here the first on the African continent
transport vehicles here are bigger and
more powerful than they are in Europe at
the moment only one out of five
manufacturers meets the minimum
standards for insulation to improve the
insulation properties with a lot of new
tracks out there with better insulation
we now we will use less diesel to to run
the cooling systems less diesel means
less carbon emissions into the
atmosphere every vehicle tested here
gets an environmental seal before long
the seal will be required on all
vehicles that transport fresh produce
abroad it tells how much fuel the
vehicle needs for refrigeration and
gives the values measured by the
temperature sensors in the testing
chamber
Ganesh
entering Johannesburg lucky thanthe a
knee has been on the road with this
vegetable truck for about an hour and a
half a special coolant helps maintain
the low temperature in the cargo area
most refrigerated trucks use this
coolant which contains a chemical that
is harmful to the environment its impact
on the atmosphere is four thousand times
greater than co2
[Music]
the trans fridge company plans on
switching to another refrigerant the
company has developed this prototype
that will soon hit the market it says
it's the world's only cooling system
that uses propane while minimizing the
risk of using the flammable substance we
use propane because it is totally
environmentally friendly it does nothing
to the ozone layer its carbon footprint
is very small
the cooling unit can be powered by a
small motor that saves on fuel costs if
everything works out as planned
the conventional environmentally harmful
coolant will no longer be used here the
company wants to install the propane
technology in all refrigeration units
for large medium and small vehicles we
will look at exporting to the local
African markets Zambia Zimbabwe Namibia
Botswana Mozambique revealed we have a
very good presence in all those markets
and once it's proven here we will
introduce it into those markets experts
estimate that by 2030 South Africa can
reduce its co2 emissions by 2 million
tons alone through better insulation and
propane based cooling units
you